you and your husband mr. Chris Pratt
have a young son Zack how old is Jack
down you see okay you posted a picture
of him online it's absolutely adorable
there he is
first of all what's going on with the
doors is that I think that that does
that thing is that to keep the evil
Santa out there scared oh yeah that's my
child proofing oh that's you child
please just the doors I remember that
you know I'm frugal in some ways and I
figured you know child proofing is a
good myself they make they they make
like at the hardware store for like 99
cents you can get a piece of plastic
that keeps us but you have them string
zombies out of your house you you guys
are you are a traditional family you
know like Thanksgiving you put up I
think I don't know if you put this on
was this on Instagram or what Chris
Chris put this on his Instagram page
yeah yes a photo from our Thanksgiving
and you had like a really an okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah we've fallen system of traditional
male-female roles and but look at it was
strong I am with it no I know look at
that you were a developer bodies yeah
yeah
you are I'm curious because you are both
actors both parents are actors your son
does he is he have the acting bug do you
think I know he's really young but is
that something you're going to encourage
or discourage Oh encouraged because I
need a back-up plan
what if you know I gotta find a way
Italy always good to think of your child
as the back-up plan wild you have yeah
well mostly me but yeah I've been trying
to teach him a little some acting your
teaching your son who's how old again
he's three these three you're trying to
teach him to act yes well here's the
thing I want I just want to be a team
you know I need to be I like to be in
charge I want to be a camp counselor I
want to be a teacher I never got to be
an acting coach I had to resort to being
an actor so so anyway I I get wish
fulfillment by giving acting lessons
you've actually brought I know you
brought a video but this is you teaching
your son a particular acting actress
well what is it as you know from the
classic scary movie one two three and
four yeah
the quadrilogy yeah yes I had to learn
how to act scared yes you know and so I
was try was you know he's not very
advanced and this is an advanced skill 3
yeah but but anyway we've been working
on this so I brought a video so you
brought a video of him you taught him I
think you try you want it to never you
want to come around the corner be scared
of it yeah bug and and because he needs
to learn how to anticipate but without
anticipating what's to take a look on
its complement your three-year-olds
acting ability being scared discovering
a bug take a look do this you're just
walking around right the normal day to
be walking the earth I mean you're early
movies whenever you were walking you
would say I'm walking it would have to
edit it out wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]